when are the nice guys on this app gonna actually turn out to be nice guys
and no offense to the nice guys that I follow
because I assume you are good people
but over and over and over
these men on this app who make
like
understanding women and combating patriarchy and misogyny part of their platform
and create these huge followings of women
turn out to be a disappointment
and those of you who are on this app
who are doing that work and also have similar platforms
you should be holding these men accountable publicly
because that's the biggest problem
that's the biggest way a man can be an ally to a woman is checking other men
it's not reading the books and understanding us and being nice to us
it's helping protect women against men who pray on women
and I'm not talking about one specific creator
but this shit just keeps happening
and I'm so sick of it and I'm so disappointed